>> Greg: HE WENT FROM RAPPER
TO SLAPPER, NOW HIS CAREER IS IN
THE CRAPPER.
HA-HA.
SEE THAT?
AND HIS DIVERSITY CONSULTANTS
MAKE BIG BUCKS.
THE FINAL PRODUCT STILL SUCKS.
SO WILL SMITH HAS RESIGNED FROM
THE ACADEMY OF MOTION PICTURE
PARTS AND SCIENCES EFFECTIVE
IMMEDIATELY IN A STATEMENT WILL
SAYS [BLEEP] YOU.
NO, I'M KIDDING.
HE SAYS --
>> I WOULD RESPECT HIM WITH
THAT.
>> Greg: I WOULD, TOO.
HE SAYS HIS ACTIONS WERE
SHOCKING, PAINFUL AND
INEXCUSABLE, LIKE WHEN HE PUTS
HIS SON IN HIS MOVIES.
SHOCKING, PAINFUL AND
INEXCUSABLE IS THE SAME THREE
WORDS TO DESCRIBE KILMEADE'S
LAST BOOK AND IT STILL WAS THE
BEST REVIEW HE GOT.
WILL SAYS HE HOPES THAT THE
ACADEMY COULD GET BACK TO THE
POWERFUL WORK IT DOES TO SUPPORT
CREATIVITY IN ARTS OF SCIENCES
AND FILM.
THE ONLY CREATIVITY THEY SHOW IS
COMING UP WITH NEW WAYS TO
PRODUCE WOKE GARBAGE, WITNESS
THE GROWING TREND OF BIAS
CONSULTANT FIRMS HIRED BY
STUDIOS TO COMB OVER THEIR
SCRIPTS AND FLAG ANYTHING THAT
PROBLEMATIC.
IT'S NOT JUST SCRIPTS BUT EVERY
LEVEL OF PRODUCTION GETS
FILTERED THROUGH A WOKE LENS.
AS LONG AS THERE'S MONEY TO BE
MADE IN CONSULTING, THERE'LL
NEVER BE AN END TO BIAS RACISM.
RUB MY FEET, GREG, IT'S THE ONLY
THING THAT BRINGS ME JOY IN THIS
WORLD.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING SAY, JOHNNIE?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO ASK YOU TO
RUB MY FEET.
I MEAN, YOU CAN BUT -- I MEAN,
I'LL NEVER KNOW IT.
>> Greg: NEITHER OF US WILL
GET ANYTHING OUT OF IT.
>> YOU CAN GIVE ME A NUB HUG.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT THAT
IS, SEE ME AFTER THE SHOW.
>> Greg: YOU'RE TERRIBLE.
HOLLYWOOD'S GONE NUTS BUT IS
THIS ABOUT MONEY NOW?
IS IT ABOUT LIKE WHEN
CONSULTANTS GET INSIDE A PLACE,
IT'S ALL ABOUT JUST GETTING
PAID.
>> THIS IS A LOT ABOUT RUNNING
FROM YOURSELF RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE IN A PLACE WHERE THESE
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO TOLD US THAT
MASCULINITY WAS TOXIC AND
VIOLENCE IS NEVER THE ANSWER.
SORRY, BUT IT'S TRUE.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
VIRTUE SIGNALED US OUT OF OUR
OWN CULTURE ACTING LIKE NORMAL
PEOPLE FOR A MINUTE AND I DON'T
MEAN THAT TO EXCUSE WILL SMITH
OR ANYTHING BUT THIS IS WHAT
NORMAL PEOPLE DO.
YOU'RE SITTING AT THE HOUSE OR
SITTING ON THE FRONT PORCH IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND SOMEONE
YELLS, YOU KNOW, SOMETHING BAD
ABOUT YOUR GIRL, YOU PUNCH HIM
IN THE FACE IT MAY NOT BE RIGHT,
BUT --
>> Greg: YOU UNDERSTAND IT.
>> I CAN UNDERSTAND IT.
IF I CAME FULL CIRCUMSTANCE
OLTHIS AND MADE IT ALL THE WAY
AROUND TO THE POINT THAT I'M
MOSTLY MAD PEOPLE CARE.
>> Greg: I QUOTE WHITE ON
THIS, IT'S BETTER ON THE WILL
SMITH FIASCO TO BE AMBIVALENT.
DO NOT TAKE ANY SIDES.
LOOK AT EVERYBODY'S DIRTY,
TAMMY.
EVERYBODY HAS A DIRTY HAND IN
THE WHOLE THING.
THE COLLISION BETWEEN A WOKE
CELEBRITY CULTURE AND HIP-HOP
CREDIBILITY JUST HEAD FIRST, YOU
KNOW?
HE HAD TO, LIKE, HE HAD TO SAY
IT.
HE HAD TO SLAP HIM EVEN THOUGH
IT WAS WRONG.
>> UNLIKE JERRY SPRINGER AND
GERALDO.
NEVER KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
>> Greg: I KNOW WHAT WILL
HAPPEN WITH GERALDO.
>> NO ONE REALLY KNOWS HOW THE
ACADEMY STARTED.
THE FILM INDUSTRY HERE STARTED
PRETTY MUCH WITH PEOPLE FROM
BURLESQUE, FROM NEW YORK, AND
THEY THOUGHT THEY REALLY NEEDED
TO TRY TO SHOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THROUGH THE NEWS REELS
THAT WOULD HAPPEN THAT THEY'RE
SERIOUS AND COULD DRESS UP AND
BE TRUSTED.
AND LOOK, WHAT IS THIS?
100 YEARS LATER AND WE'RE BACK
TO SMACKING EACH OTHER ON THE
FACE ON THE STAGE.
FOR ME WAS SHOCKING WAS -- I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT SOMETIMES
YOU GO MAYBE YOU NEED TO SLAP
SOMEONE WHO OFFENDS YOUR WIFE,
IF THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
DID HE NOT REMEMBER HE WAS AT
THE ACADEMY AWARDS?
DID HE NOT -- BUT -- AND HE WAS
LAUGHING.
SHE GOT UPSET APPARENTLY FROM
THE -- AND SHE LOOKED AT HIM AND
WAS CLEARLY UPSET ABOUT IT.
AND THAT IS WHEN HE THEN DECIDED
TO GO AND DO THAT EXTRAORDINARY
THING.
BUT IT SEEMED TO BE SUCH A BREAK
FROM REALITY.
THAT IS WHY AMERICANS DIDN'T GET
IT, BECAUSE YOU KNOW, YOU GROW
UP LOVING FILM AND YOU WANT TO
HAVE THIS BE A BREAK FROM
REALITY AND SUDDENLY IT'S NOT.
ON TOP OF THAT, NOBODY KNOWS WHO
WON THE OSCARS EXCEPT HIM.
THERE'S NO DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
MOVIES OR ANYTHING ELSE AND
THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN SOME GOOD
STUFF!
>> I WOULDN'T HAVE KNOWN.
>> I NEVER DO, YEAH.
>> AND LIKE EVEN WITH THAT BUMP,
IT ABYSMAL RATING, SO WHAT --
>> Greg: IT WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
THE WORST IF IT WASN'T FOR WILL.
>> DOES HE HAVE TO GIVE HIS
TROPHY BACK OR IS HE
INCONSEQUENTIAL.
>> HE NEEDS TO GO AWAY FOR A
YEAR.
>> THEY'RE STILL INVESTIGATING
HIM.
>> IT'S ALSO HILARIOUS, HE'S
SUCH A CONTROL FREAK AND HE'S SO
FULL OF SELF IMPORTANCE THAT HE
QUITS THE ACADEMY.
HE CAN'T WAIT FOR THEIR
JUDGMENT.
HE'S LIKE, I DON'T CARE.
I DON'T NEED YOU.
AND YOU'RE LIKE, BITCH, THEY
JUST INVITED YOU TO A PARTY AND
YOU CRY!
>> IT HAPPENS.
>> IT DOES HAPPEN.
>> Greg: USUALLY YOU GO TO THE
BROOM CLOSET.
>> NO ONE TALKED ABOUT THE
FANTASTIC JOB CHRIS ROCK DID FOR
TAKING THAT SLAP AND MOVING ON
WITH THE SHOW BECAUSE I'M
TELLING YOU, I WOULD STILL BE ON
THE GROUND.
I'D STILL THEREBY.
OH MY GOSH, I GOT WHIPLASH.
I'M GOING TO SUE.
I'D BE TALKING LAWYERS.
>> Greg: DO YOU FIND IT WEIRD
THERE WERE SO MANY MOVIES UP FOR
THE OSCARS?
IT'S ALMOST LIKE HOLLYWOOD
REALLY DIDN'T PARTICIPATE IN THE
LOCKDOWN.
DID YOU NOTICE THAT?
WHAT IF WE DID AN AWARDS SHOW --
>> THEY DIDN'T PARTICIPATE IN
THE LOCKDOWNS BECAUSE THEY
FILMED THEIR MOVIES IN GEORGIA
AND OUR GOVERNOR DIDN'T HAVE A
LOCKDOWN.
MARCH 16, 2020, THAT WENT AWAY
FOR US.
>> BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC, THEY
DIDN'T HAVE -- IF YOU'RE A RICH,
FAMOUS CELEBRITY, THEN IT
DOESN'T APPLY TO YOU.
>> Greg: TELL ME ABOUT IT.
>> YOU GET IT.
AND THAT'S ALSO WHY WILL SMITH
HAD THE EXACT SAME APOLOGY AS
EVERY OTHER RICH CELEBRITY.
IT WAS EXACTLY THE SAME.
IT WAS AS ALL OF THEM.
HE SAID I'M SO SORRY.
THERE'S NO EXCUSE.
I ACCEPT EVERY CONSEQUENCE AND I
WILL DO THE WORK.
IT WAS SO WEIRD TO SEE THIS
APOLOGY OVER A PHYSICAL ASSAULT
ALMOST LIKE CHRIS HARRISON'S
APOLOGY WHEN HE RESIGNED FROM
THE BACHELOR OVER SOMETHING HE
SAID.
>> Greg: RIGHT, SO TRUE.
>> YOU SHOULD PRINT THOSE OUT.
>> Greg: COMING UP, HE'S GLAD
TO BE RID O